fundraising time for the presidential
candidates the latest data in for
Democratic frontrunner Hillary Clinton
names like Tesla's Elon Musk Facebook
Sheryl Sandberg Hollywood uber producer
and director Steven Spielberg and of
course Jeff Katzenberg are among the
biggest donors to her campaign in the
last quarter secretary Hillary Clinton
raised 8.1 million dollars in California
that's seventy percent of the total of
forty seven million that she raised in
the latest quarter according to federal
filings in the meantime Republican
hopeful Jeb Bush raised more than 144
thousand dollars for more than 50
goldman sachs bankers most of them
donated the maximum 2700 hours dollars
allowed mark crumpton joins me now for
more surprising sheryl sandberg told
Bloomberg back in April I'd like to see
her mrs. Clinton as president and I'd
like to see more women presidents all
over the world so I guess we kind of
knew where her money was going but this
is not something that is is an unusual
not at all that Wall Street banker
support Republicans is unsurprising not
at all and that Hollywood and Silicon
Valley supports Democratic frontrunner
that's unsurprising as well we in this
Bloomberg story here it says that
creative artists agency ranked among the
best places for mrs. Clinton to raise
money more than 50 employees from the
talent agency donated a total of more
than eighty thousand dollars other top
California money sources included
employees at Facebook and at Google so
they're tapping into that star power
again as they usually do and of course
there's always been the complaint at
least from Republican circles that
California and Hollywood have a liberal
bias and the money seems to bear the mid
things to write this seems to be the
perfect evidence for them it's also
perfect evidence for Republicans who say
that Hillary Clinton is out of touch
with the public that she mixes among the
elites you know you can't get any more
elite then than some of the Hollywood
movers and shakers you might say the
game of course for the wall street
bankers themselves but but look I mean
this is a little bit of fuel i would say
for her opponents who say she is you
know she's with the one person
at the top 0.5% even just out of touch
with the middle class you know that's an
interesting thing because when you
struggle to make money and then all of a
sudden you make money yeah people say
that you're out of touch remember the
legal bills that the Clintons had well
that's another story to next hour we're
going to keep talking about Greece as
you say and we mean this with all due
respect but it's the stories like the
gift that keeps on giving there is so
many different facets to this story and
von prossies the managing director
sovereign risk at Moody's she's going to
be joining us to talk about what is
going on with Greece now that the
parliament has passed these anti
austerity measures which a lot of people
say are more draconian than the ones
that they agreed to back earlier this
year so it's a little more a chokehold
on the economy mark